ja es ist viel vertrauende verloren
gegangen es gibt auch noch weiterhin
viele Streitpunkte in der Koalition vor
allem auch bei der wärmewende Reichen
bleibt so viel ist klar Robert Habeck
hat jetzt den Kollegen von der ARD ein
Interview gegeben und hat darin seine
vorgehen so erklärt
mehreren Wochen das mit einer Härte und
fast Böswilligkeit Unterstellungen
Beleidigung teilweise Lügen verbreitet
werden um ein Ziel durchzusetzen die
Verhinderung der dekarbonisierung des
Klimaschutzes im Wärmebereich und da bin
ich nicht bereit Menschen zu Opfern um
dieser Kampagne nachzugeben also wir
hören uns spricht davon einer Kampagne
und möchte für diese keine Menschen
auffangen kann man so übersetzen alle
die ihn jetzt kritisieren sind im
Prinzip auch gegen den Klimaschutz
zumindest manche hören das so raus klar
ist Habeck steht derzeit sehr in der
Kritik und das ist jetzt auch das Thema
von ex-regierung Sprecher
ja das was wir gerade gesehen haben das
war starker Tobak von Robert Habeck wir
hatten eigentlich gedacht er hätte diese
Phase überwunden diese Phase der
angefasstheit der mimosität doch gestern
dieser schlimme Rückfall in den
Tagesthemen im Interview mit Herrn
zamperoni hat gesagt na ja weil da war
der missverstanden wir haben es gesehen
der das richtige will und der von allen
bösen Mächten gejagt wird Bild natürlich
inklusive natürlich auch die CDU dabei
hatte der Moderator ja nur gefragt ob es
bei diesen Familien filzvorwürfen den
havix Ministerium nicht auch so ist dass
sie mit doppelter ja mit doppelten
Maßstäben gemessen wird dass die Grünen
nicht gut im Austeilen aber sehr
schlecht im einstecken sind doch habe
ich die sich gar nicht darauf eine sagte
nein Fehler wurden gemacht es gibt ein
neues Verfahren doch in Wahrheit geht es
bei den Attacken um seinen
Staatssekretär nur darum die
dekarbonisierung unserer
heizungswirtschaft zu bekämpfen und
deswegen wir haben es gehört eigentlich
bereit
Opfer zu bringen bzw Menschen zu Opfern
so die Lisa wie sind die Opfer weil wir
die Heizungsart der deutschen
modernisieren wollen deswegen werden wir
gejagt das passt der Lobby nicht so
sieht's nämlich aus doch damit macht es
sich Robert habe Weg zu einfach erinnern
wir uns in Rollen gebracht hatte diese
abwehren nämlich die Links alternative
Tanz
der hat heute noch mal nach die
nachgelegt in einem Interview mit der
Vorsitzenden der aufklärungsorganisation
transparen sie international hat sie
gesagt nein habe ich muss sie mehr
aufklären und hat die Vorwürfe gegen ihn
schwerwiegen genannt ich finde habe ich
wirklich darauf einstellen müssen dass
der Honeymoon mit der deutschen
Öffentlichkeit vorbei ist er ist
sozusagen angekommen wirklich angekommen
in Berlin ob es realisiert hat das wage
ich zu bezweifeln
hast du das Gefühl Robert Habeck hat
sein Haus seine Politik derzeit noch in
Griff ja er hat dir was ganz auch
bizarres gemacht er hat sich ja vor sein
Haus gestellt und gesagt so kann man mit
den Mitarbeitern die hier alle 14
Stunden am Tag arbeiten um die
Energiewende hinzubekommen um die
dekarbonisierung zu sichern um uns die
Gasspeicher zu wollen so kann man mit
den Mitarbeitern nicht umgehen weil ja
gar nicht das Thema weil niemand hat ja
sein Haus kritisiert oder die tausenden
von Mitarbeitern dort sondern sein
Umgang in der Führungsspitze des Hauses
darum geht es und ähm
gerade er ist natürlich er selber ist
angefressen glaube ich sehr stark weil
er natürlich diese beispiellose
Zustimmung hatte weit voran Alina Bär
Bock die natürlich noch die innere
Rivale ist auch im Kampf um wenn sie
denn so wollen sie haben es heute gesagt
die Kanzlerkandidatur da hat er sich
natürlich im Lied und jetzt dieser
Rückschritt auch mich Stimmung in der
Bevölkerung über diesen Heizungsmarkt
dann diese Sachen mit dem Familien
und zum ersten Mal seine doch etwas
geliebte CDU die ja immer hofiert hat
und wo immer so ein bisschen kokettiert
hat mit ich könnte ja auch mit denen
auf einmal holt sie in Kiel gestern im
Bundestag und in den Ausschüssen und wie
sahen gestern wie verwundert habe war
dass das auf einmal mit ihm passiert
also da hat er wirklich nerven gezeigt
und nicht nur ähm nicht nur aus Kritik
aus der sogenannten rechten Ecke sondern
das war ja unison nur dass Meinungsbild
im in allen Medien gefährlich glaubst du
so kann das werden für Harbeck aber auch
für die Koalition für die Koalition sehe
ich da keine Gefahr außer dass die
Zustimmung weiter weiter fällt natürlich
und dass man irgendwann sagt was man auf
du musst da was tun nicht er selber hat
ja erklärt er stellt sich vor seinem
wichtigsten Staatssekretär der mit ihm
diese ganze Energiewende organisiert und
ist nicht bereit da
Opfer zu bringen aber er kann natürlich
weiter zurückfahren werden in Bremen die
Auswirkungen sehen sicherlich wenn das
noch Richtungswahl
am Sonntag Richtung Wahl werden aber wir
wenn es denn sieht ja so aus dass die
SPD offenkundig da gewinnen kann
vielleicht die CD auch ein bisschen es
werden wir werden Auswirkungen sehen
dieser Affäre bei den Grünen das glaube
ich schon und wir werden die Bürger in
Wut erleben die AFD kann er nicht
antreten
möglicherweise also wir sehen dann den
Bevölkerung der auch hochkommen aber
insofern wird die SPD hochgeht wird es
keine Richtungswahl sein aber es wird
vielleicht ein den Zettel für die grün
herr Ulrich was glauben Sie wie kommt
das Interview dass wir hier gerade in
Ausschnitten gezeigt haben bei den
Menschen bei den Bürgern bei den
Wählerinnen und Wählern so an ich habe
es tatsächlich gestern in den
Tagesthemen gesehen das erste was mir
dazu einfiel war so ähnlich sachwidrige
Verknüpfung ja was hat das Eine Thema
mit dem anderen Thema zu tun einfach
sozusagen ein Anliegen zu verknüpfen mit
dem persönlichen Filz der ihm
vorgeworfen wird der hat sein Haus
entsprechend so zu halten was jeder
normaler eben andere auch von ihm
erwartet da nicht seine persönlichen
Interessen weiter zu verfolgen und in
früheren Zeiten wäre das dass der Gang
nach Hause gewesen ja also ein normaler
Bürger begreift das nicht dass das im
Grunde genommen jetzt sozusagen der neue
Stil der Politik sein soll das können
wir einmal weitergeben will an dich als
ehemalige Regierungssprecher gerade
haben wir in früheren Zeiten auch ein
Grund für einen Rücktritt gewesen
wäre auch gab es auch sind wir die Frage
wie fest ist die Bande zwischen den
beiden was sagt ich meine die wir haben
eine eine wir haben die Kompetenzen in
den in den wir haben die
Richtlinienkompetenz des Bundeskanzlers
wir haben aber die Kompetenzen natürlich
in den Ministerien jeder Minister kann
sein Amt so führen wie er es will etwas
übersetzt gesagt und wenn Robert habe
ich gesagt ich halte an ihm fest an
Herrn reichen dann kann er an ihm
festhalten und wir werden sehen wie
lange das geht nach jetzigen Stand muss
er ihn nicht entlassen nur wenn weiter
Vorwürfe kommen und öffentlich werden
sollten dann ist es eine andere Sache
und wenn dadurch die ganze Koalition
weiter runtergezogen wird mit Ausnahme
der FDP die zu profitieren scheint dann
stellt sich auch die Frage wie sinnhaft
ist das Vorgehen noch und dann wird es
natürlich eine Frage auch die innerhalb
des rot grünen Lagers besprochen werden
muss ja wenn weitere Informationen dann
an die Öffentlichkeit kommen in dem Fall
spricht ja Robert habe gesagt er gerne
von Kampagne ist nicht genau dass sie
Aufgabe von Jo und müssen die Grünen und
auch Robert Habeck die ich genau das
auch aushalten wenn man in der Regierung
ist Verantwortung trägt auch aushalten
dass eben ganz genau auf dieser Arbeit
geschaut wird absolut das müssten Sie
das hat aber auch offensichtlich mit dem
grünen Selbstverständnis was zu tun
nämlich sozusagen wie sind die guten wir
haben hier Experten reingebracht und
dann sieht man da ist so ein Filz und
klüngelnetzwerk was die Grünen bei
anderen weil bei der FDP z.B sofort
kritisieren würden und sowieso ist doch
alles ist doch alles gar nicht so
schlimm die Frage ist aber warum
reagieren die Grünen eigentlich so
unsachlich ne das ist ja ähm Jugend hat
sogar noch schärfer formuliert gesagt
das ist eine von rechts indizierte
Kampagne das gab es auch schon mal wir
erinnern uns bei Frau bärbox Buch im
Wahlkampf sie hatte ja ein Buch
geschrieben
also gar nicht mehr darum sind die
Vorwürfe jetzt zu treffen oder nicht das
ist irgendwas von rechts und so dann
versuchen muss man natürlich das ist
rhetorisch selber gemacht muss man sich
mit dem Vorwürfen gar nicht mehr
auseinandersetzen sondern einfach wir
damit einsteigt auf diese
Kampagnen und so und jetzt erleben die
grün aber in der Regierung wenn man in
der Regierung Verantwortung trägt dann
kommt man damit so nicht mehr durch und
das das kriegt der habe ich jetzt gerade
zu spüren wir sehen ja auch er sieht
geknickt aus er hat wenig Schlaf wir
müssen auch erst mal davon erzählt dass
er nur noch quasi die hinten sind
ungebügelt und er ist seine und das war
vor der Wahl
mit Wasser so also er kriegt jetzt
wirklich auch mal den eigenen hohen
moralischen Anspruch den er selbst immer
ja formuliert und wo er andere dann
accountable erhält sagt
glaubst du dass die grüne in der
Vergangenheit vielleicht für manchen
Medien auch zu sehr verhätschelt wurden
zuliebe sprich man ist es vielleicht gar
nicht gewohnt so in der Kritik zu stehen
und reagiert aus diesem Grund so das
Ding ist tatsächlich man merkt auch
dieses Thema ist jetzt erst so groß
durchgebrochen Bild hat frühzeitig
berichtet auch andere auch die Tatsache
wie gesagt auch Frankfurter Rundschau
das sind klassische linke Zeitung in dem
Fall aber so richtig durchgebrochen ist
das eigentlich erst als der Spiegel das
große aufgegriffen hat so und das sind
die Grünen halt nicht gewohnt ne die
Spiegel war ja früher ach mensch Werbung
und habe ich der also
aber geht was ganz Neues das ist so
inspirierend oder auch die Zeit war ja
nun sehr auf die Süddeutsche sehr
positiv dass die Grünen jetzt
möglicherweise sogar die Kanzlerschaft
stehen das war ja auch Habicht großer
Traum bevor Frau Bär wird dann an die
vorbei gezogen ist das hat sich jetzt
alles für den Moment erstmal erledigt
toll
wie nerviger Busen ist das für sie wenn
dann wenn ein Koalitionspartner wenn wir
mal bei dem Bild dass wir hier
gezeichnet haben bleiben auf Kritik ähm
so wird es hier gerade gesagt in einem
bestimmten Muster reagiert dann ist man
gegen das Klima oder man kommt aus der
rechten Ecke oder man unterstützt nicht
das Gute das moralische nervt das ja
klar das nennt mich also total und vor
allem die Argumentation dass er sagt die
Lügen und kommt von rechts und so weiter
ich weiß nicht was da Lüge wo ich eine
Lüge gehört habe das sind Schwäger
Schwager Bruder Schwester da gibt's
nichts zu lügen klar benannt worden ich
habe zweimal die Aktuelle Stunde
miterlebt und der hat keiner gelogen
nach meiner Ansicht und ähm Haarwerk
gibt es ja auch viele viele andere Dinge
die also persönlich Nerven weil er hat
da nun ein Minister braucht man mal
keinen zertifizierungsnachweis da
braucht man keine Ausbildung und das
fachwirtschaft ist schon sehr
kompliziert in Deutschland wir haben
viele Dinge erlebt ob das Insolvenz
waren und solche Geschichten und jetzt
bitte mit dem Gebäude Energiegesetz was
sind das alles Dinge die von ihm auf den
Weg gebracht wurden die die Menschen
völlig verunsichert haben die völlig aus
der Luft gegriffen also ich bin selbst
Bauingenieur und habe viele Häuser
gebaut wie kann man sowas in die Welt
setzen ab Januar 24 wird nicht mehr mit
Gas geheizt funktioniert doch einfach
gar nicht ich kann da auch nicht sagen
zu meinem Wecker du kriegst am Morgen
kein Mehl mehr Sie zu wie die Brötchen
fertig bekommen
das nervt mich total weil es da fehlte
entweder fehlt der Menschenverstand und
der Sachverstand ist aber jetzt fast so
als wenn sie Oppositionspolitiker
links und rechts versuchen alles hin zu
kitten nein das ist ein dieser Fehler in
seinem Ministerium und er hat einfach
nicht die Qualifikation das hat sich
doch jetzt gezeigt und da muss man ihm
sagen so mein Freund entweder du machst
jetzt was du setzt sie mal hin und
überlegst vernünftig bevor du was
rausschleudert was nicht machbar ist
draußen mit den Menschen das Gefühl dass
diese Kritik dann sozusagen das passt
jetzt sehr gut auf grünen Boden fällt
also haben Sie das Gefühl dass wenn man
da Klartext spricht wenn Sie vielleicht
mit Frau gering Eckert mal beim Kaffee
sitzen machen sie das Nein sollten wir
uns vorstellen sie ist ihr Koalition sie
sind mit in der Regierung ne also ich
stelle mir vor dass man da ab und zu mal
beieinander sitzen genauso solche
Gespräche führt also in den
Fachbereichen zusammen aber ansonsten
werden passiert das nicht so oft gibt's
irgendeinen Ansprechpartner bei den
Grünen wo sie sagen da komme ich weiter
da können wir doch doch bei meinen
Koalitionspartnern in Sachen Wald und
und Forst und so weiter da sind wir
immer auf konstruktivere Ebene arbeiten
wir gut zusammen
das funktioniert
ein junger Kollege von den Grünen ist
von Beruf Förster
Komfort studiert der weiß worüber er
redet dann kann man auch Politik machen
wenn man natürlich jetzt nicht der
Bereich wo es am meisten knarzt gerade
in Deutschland kann man sagen
aber das sind natürlich nicht die Themen
die viele umtreiben wie schwierig ist
das für sie das glauben Sie wie lange
ich habe sie schon mal gefragt aber ich
stelle es mir wirklich schwierig vor so
Politik zu machen wie lange geht das
noch gut würden sie da ihre Hand drauf
schön dass sie sagen bis zur nächsten
Wahl bleibt diese Koalition schon meine
Hand drauf schwören aber ich gehe davon
aus dass das gut geht und das da müssen
wir uns auch zusammenraufen und das wird
auch funktionieren das glaube ich auch
dem was ist die Alternative gibt es ja
nicht also wer soll damit wem koalieren
es bliebe ja nur die Ampel oder die
große Koalition aber ich weiß nicht da
gibt es doch kein Interesse bei der FDP
auch nicht mit den Grünen oder den
Sozialdemokraten das jetzt das jetzt in
diese Konstellation zu führen also genau
die Ampel als Rettung vor der also als
die die die die Jamaika als Rettung vor
der Ampel ich meine wenn man sieht wie
die CDU die Grünen als als
mobilisierungsmasse benutzt oder die CSU
jetzt gerade im Wahlkampf in Bayern und
den mit denen zusammenzugehen völlig
absurd manche wünschen sich Sebastian
vielleicht sogar neue Wahlen glaubst du
dass dieser Wunsch bei einigen Menschen
immer mehr blüht die gibt es bestimmt
wir haben ja zum Beispiel gesehen dass
das Wählerpotenzial der AFD gestiegen
ist oder warum zwei Prozent wenn also
alle Menschen jetzt schon in den Umfang
sagen sie würden AFD wählen und die die
sich das grundsätzlich vorstellen können
das machen würden hätte die AFD 26 % in
Deutschland das ist eine enorme Zahl ist
das ein Grund für Neuwagen
müssen muss man sagen da werden also ein
paar Mandate dann weg das kann insofern
die FDP eigentlich nicht wollen deswegen
werden sie das auch nicht machen sondern
wird sich direkt wird sich dann
zusammenraufen
um Neuwahlen stattfinden zu lassen also
zurück zur großen Koalition
also mir ist das letztendlich alles
wurste denn wir bekommen immer das
gleiche egal wen wir wählen egal welche
Farbe wir hatten es wird auf dem Bürger
als wäre das immer das gleiche ja und
letztendlich ist das was wir da bekommen
ja ich meine Herr Seehofer hat ja sehr
schön ausgedrückt
diejenigen die die Macht haben wurden
nicht gewählt und äh die sozusagen
gewählt wurden haben nicht die Macht und
so scheint es auch in vielen Bereichen
weil es doch sehr Interessen geschrieben
scheint und für viele Themen und auch
der Bürger sieht das mittlerweile das
klingt muss ich sagen ein Stück weit
resigniert und damit gehen wir eine ganz
kurze Pause wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie